nous
nous avons des problèmes sérieux grable
son transport public depuis 2010 de
neige
on peut dire qu'elle à la fois cynthia
patterson est prêtre anglican et fervent
de militante elle a mené des batailles
épiques pendant plus de trente ans pour
conserver le trait en gaspésie mais elle
a perdu et même si le gouvernement a
promis de le ramener en 2025 elle n'a
pas l'intention de s'arrêter ses talents
c'est pas que le gouvernement ne veut
pas approprié l'argent pour ça c'est les
différentes priorités le gouvernement
certes les choix qui favorisait la vie
urbaine elle néglige tout le monde dans
le vie à laura
[Musique]
le projet de réfection en cours visent à
rétablir le service sur 325 km de rails
la section autres matapédia et new
richmond est déjà fonctionnel mais le
plus important reste à faire desservir
toute la côte sud de la péninsule
jusqu'à gaspé pôle d'attraction
touristique et pivot du développement
économique
la réhabilitation du train de passagers
doit d'abord être précédée par la mise
en service du train de marchandises pour
servir de gros de très gros clients
comme le fabricant de pales d'éoliennes
lm power propriété de la multinationale
américaine general electric malgré
l'absence de chemin de fer lm wind power
fabricant de pales d'éoliennes en russie
car même à exporter sa et ses
composantes
mais les composants doivent se taper
plus de 200 kilomètres sur la route avec
les surcoûts qui sert occasionne et
l'impact que cela sur la compétitivité
de l'entreprise
chaque jour des convois de voitures de
sécurité et des policiers doivent
accompagner les camions qui transportent
c'est pal géante sur les routes de la
gaspésie
avant qu'elle ne soit transbordée sur
des trains à destination des états unis
des manoeuvres lourdes et coûteuses pour
l'entreprise et pour l'environnement
depuis dix ans le chemin de fer est
complètement fermée
donc oui on passe des opportunités
heureusement eu un plan d'investissement
à moyen terme qui vont nous redonner cet
outil de développement pour 2025
la réfection du chemin de fer
aujourd'hui propriété du gouvernement du
québec est un projet de plus de 250
millions de dollars la supervision des
travaux et l'exploitation de la partie
fonctionnelle du rail revienne à un
organisme public local ce qu'on veut
c'est augmenter le volume s'assurer que
cet outil là ça soit un levier de
développement économique pour tout
l'ensemble du territoire et ce à travers
quatre mrc
il ya des entreprises qui peuvent
bénéficier de notre sort
[Musique]
perpète ac j'ai besoin du train pour
fermer mon développement la reprise les
entreprises de gaspésie comme celle ci
qui fabrique des plaquettes de frais
pour éoliennes compte sur le retour du
train pour relancer l'économie de la
région je pense qu'à douze entreprises
pourraient se développer en parle de
série d'autres dans d'autres entreprises
mais qui ne peuvent pas se développer
parce qu'il n'y a pas de moyen de
transport à économie axée sur canaille à
la voie ferrée il va développer d'autres
idées d'autres projets
le train
c'est très très important pour
l'industrie touristique de la gaspésie
et moi personnellement comme
entrepreneur au quart de l'industrie
touristique ça devient essentiel
claudine roy propriétaire d'une auberge
à gaspé et organisatrice de multiples
événements culturels rêve du retour du
train dans son coin de pays pas
seulement pour ses affaires mais aussi
pour le développement de modes de vie
plus écologique
les gens sont de plus en plus écolo ici
on a quand même une population qui
vieillit qui veulent aller à l'hôpital
c'est pas tout le monde qui veulent ça
tapait le 10 heures à montréal gaspé en
voiture non plus hein puis on est ce que
l'on beaucoup de monde devant l'histoire
le retour du très va permettre selon
elle de développer le tourisme à
longueur d'année et pas seulement en été
on est rendu là et il faut vraiment
qu'on se donne les moyens aussi que le
transport par autobus c'est très
restreint les billets d'avion c'est
extrêmement cher le pascal qui a pris la
relève mais il reste que c'est pas tout
le monde qui peut prendre l'avion et
c'est pas tout le monde qui peut
à cause des températures
les travaux avancent comme prévu même
plus rapidement sur certains chantiers
si bien que des groupes de citoyens
réclament bethenod l'accès aux trains de
passagers dès l'an prochain pour une
partie du parcours et en 2023 plutôt que
2025 pour l'ensemble du projet nous
n'avons pas le transport public c'est
très difficile je peux rassurer les gens
au travail pour le ramener le plus
rapidement possible gaspé en langue big
mac ça se prononce gâche bègles et pillé
gâche pas ça veut dire la fin d'êta
c'est le bout du monde alors
oui il ya de la place il ya de
l'ouverture et puis il faut qu'on amène
du monde on est peut-être le roi de la
région montréalaise monde est plus
proche des dépôts que sont l'europe qui
sont la côte est américaine on apprend
de mer en eau profonde le spread flash
un collé sur le port où il ya une
perspective de développer
l'intermodalité de façon assez
impressionnante c'est la guerre la plus
belle par tout le monde nommé notre
guide laroche et perçait la compagnie
via rail responsable du service de train
de passagers a promis de le rétablir
quand tous les travaux de réfection
seront terminés pas avant mais les
gaspésiens ne lâche pas prise
c'est une question de justice sociale et
une question de justice
économique les citoyens de la gaspésie
veulent retrouver rapidement un service
de transport qui juge essentiel et un
mode de vie plus respectueux de la
nature et des traditions
[Musique]